the plane got into difficulty after a
flock of birds was sucked into the
engines upon takeoff causing both
engines to cut out the pilots of flight
used six one seven eight managed to land
the plane on its belly in a cornfield
just over a kilometer from the runway
without as I mentioned either engine
landing gear or even being able to dump
fuel everyone on board survived
officials report that 74 people were
injured during the emergency landing now
this video was taken from inside the
stricken Airbus a321 as it accelerated
along the runway with 226 passengers and
7 crew on board it's been announced that
Russia will honour the two hero pilots
for the remarkable feat of averting what
could have been an horrific disaster
officials say the two weren't seriously
and should now return to work following
medical examinations remain Casa of
reports from the crash site in southeast
Moscow 226 passengers and 7 crew members
of Ural Airlines flight bound for Crimea
from Moscow are celebrating their second
birthday the airbus a321 collided with a
flock of birds just shortly after
takeoff from the Capitals Zhukovsky
Airport the captain Zamir Yusupov had
just seconds to make the right decision
when he discovered this strike caused
engine failure with 16 tons of fuel on
board and no ability to make it back to
the runway he knew that an emergency
landing could result in a catastrophe
little bro after we took off the engines
became unstable first left one and then
the right one
we usually simulate these situations
when one or two engines are off despite
all our efforts the plane was going down
we realized that we didn't have much
time just one or two minutes to make a
decision in a blink of an eye this man
with nerves of steel decided to land the
aircraft in a nearby cornfield without
using the landing gear and shutting off
all power to prevent an explosion what
could have been a tragedy has turned
into a miracle with all passengers and
crew safely stepping their feet on the
ground reacted in the line of our
instructions
of simulated situations like this before
rehearsed them there were no surprises
the passengers were disciplined listen
to our commands and evacuate a very
quickly overcome down but the cabin crew
they told us that everything was fine we
were given medical assistance everything
was done quickly and would like to
express my gratitude to the pilot who
was flying the plane I think we are all
alive thanks to him tell us please how
do you feel now did you hurt your leg
you know it's better than if I was there
lying on the field so everything is
rather good the landing was good the
pilots did a great job landed the plane
on its belly everything is fine the
media was a quick to make connections
with another such incident when loss of
life was averted thanks to a pilot the
miracle on the Hudson involving a US
Airways aircraft flown by captain
Chesley Sullenberger and Jeffrey's
Kyle's hit a flock of geese after
takeoff from New York City's LaGuardia
Airport and lost all engine power unable
to land at any available Airport they
had to ditch the jet in the Hudson River
just outside of Manhattan with all of
the 155 passengers rescued by nearby
ferries and boats Russia now has its own
national hero with the country's Health
Ministry reporting that the lives of
those people who requested medical
assistance was not under any threat
thanks to the heroics all for the
captain and his crew relatives and loved
ones of all the people involved we'll
get to see them again the airline and
various officials praised the crew for
their professionalism
during the spine-chilling landing as
well as for well organized evacuation
Ramon Kozlov RT Moscow region echoing
that aviation experts we've been
speaking to say the pilots made the
right decisions under extreme pressure I
take my hat off to the to the pilots and
to everybody on board the crew and the
passengers because this was a textbook
emergency landing the video I've just
seen of it it was absolutely amazing I
think he took a calculated risk he said
right
we are too near the ground by the time
the landing gear gets down it might not
have locked in place we'll go for what
we call a belly flop and that's
basically what he did and he landed it
beautifully and this is a bit like the
if you remember the Hudson River
incidents when the plane landed on the
lake the whole point is that he brought
it down with the nose slightly up and so
literally it sailed over the corn field
and that's quite a robust crop so that's
helped the landing these pilots did
brilliantly because they were really
quite low when the bird strike took
place and the engine power dropped awake
almost completely so they had to look
around for an open space in which to
land and they did that and as you can
see they've done it brilliantly
you